today we're gonna be labeling a map of
Europe doesn't that look like Europe you
guys remember how Russia's that really
tall country you know from maps if you
drop me in the middle of my hometown I
couldn't tell you where I was where I
was going it's gonna be real bad why
couldn't you give us a Mercator
projection this is not a map anybody's
seen you guys have been intentionally
deceptive you would have gotten it past
us if you've given us the normal maps
not like you need to make it more
difficult we're ignorant Americans we
weren't going to get this anyways oh is
that how we're gonna come across
of course it's how we're gonna come
across what do you think the frame of
this video is strategy is do the ones we
know first well I'm glad you have one
try to label the biggest land masses
because that's the most embarrassing if
we miss my whole game strategy is just
get a hundred percent okay so we were
given a list of countries and I was
given the order to change my shirt so I
don't blend in over here feeling bad but
let's do this we have ten minutes on the
clock and those stars now this is all
water yes unless we're just like
crossing off a bunch of countries but
you know whatever
Great Britain okay is an island that's
an island well next to Great Britain
then we probably are going with like
Ireland this year I know for sure this
is Thanks so I will do that and I know
this is France can you please put France
how do you pronounce it France what am I
saying
Fran France France France yeah we're
saying this Frances yeah I have to base
this off of what I remember back in the
day from like old Queens and like kings
of like Great Britain so I know that
like they all had like incestuous
relationships with like France and like
journey it's always gonna make sense in
a moment France match France
okay that's Germany okay Germany Wow
okay I really feel like I'm only going
to hold you back hear this okay so I
know that this it's Portugal all right
this is Russia Spain Spain okay and
that's ports myself it's brains this is
the United Kingdom this is Ireland we
know that this is Denmark nope
this is
I'm a dress wants to stop there these
three countries think this is the
Netherlands this is Sweden this is
Finland I know this is sweet let's do
sweetie
Finland's on top of it I think that's
the net oh now I'm nervous no yes you're
right so these three um are NSF and I
always wanted this to be W but it's not
it's Russia
so it's Norway Sweden Finland I like it
on the record that I don't know if
that's good this is like frozen lands
like I imagine that like it frozen took
place it has got to be one of these
three places also we know this is Italy
that's Italy that's a nice because it's
a nice boot Greece okay from Sound of
Music I know this is Austria that means
Switzerland's here that's not part of
the Europe I know that's not my Europe I
believe Amsterdam is here and I forget
which country Amsterdam is in but I
remember the city is here and that you
know what country is in right yesterday
a man thinks in the Netherlands though
wait a minute
Oh Cyprus is its own Island I think this
is Cyprus Yeah right is that you have a
better guest for Cyprus I sure don't
this is Greece right that's Greece then
this is nope we're gonna come this is
Switzerland we know that yeah let's do
that
the Vatican yeah which is like here is
right right this has got to be Denmark
right the names in Denmark that sounds
about right
I mean I don't really know Turkey right
is this Turkey sure Ukraine is next to
Russia
which one's Ukraine are bigger is better
sure that's the one all right you
created this is Poland and that means
Austria is underneath it yes sound of
music is with ha today I think this is
Montenegro and Serbia is next to it oh
really yeah because they they partner up
for the Olympics I'd like to phone a
friend
they're fake countries on here no okay
welcome Iceland
hold on one of these might be Norway I'm
pretty sure this isn't oh this can't be
right God Slovakia Slovenia I'm just
gonna it's assuming it's yeah we're just
gonna say this is a USSR yeah there's an
Estonia over there
Texas covers like that much okay I'm
gonna say this is Belgium this is
Netherlands that's what it is
Belgium okay so one of these is lifting
seeing one of these is Luxembourg think
this is Montenegro I think this is
Denmark
that one's Denmark this is Turkey cuz it
borders Syria should be down right we
just gotta start labeling so then what
do you want sabaki entity I want
Slovakia to be here great that looks
great Slovakia to put Denmark down here
Denmark is here so I'm gonna say one of
these is Georgia one of these is Armenia
Croatia Croatia I'm not confident in how
we did we found out we got 18 out of 49
right which is not passing I'm proud
that we identified this is water yes
honestly really well done so we ended up
getting 23 out of 49 that's really good
maybe your guys at home weren't
celebrating but that's pretty darn good
that is not half but it is really good I
think a lot of central or Eastern Europe
is just gonna be very difficult the
former USSR I mean those are new
countries you gotta give us time to
figure out where those things are give
us a hundred years how you really
learned something is if you're actually
visiting there and can actually like get
to experience it so not having that
experience to kind of cement a memory
and I'm just going off what I've seen on
maps and history books because we're in
the States we learn the states in the
regions in America a lot more if you're
in Europe you probably learn these
because it's like and you travel to them
a lot more love to see all your
beautiful countries Europeans and learn
the names of them
[Music]